now this is a notable moment because  in criticizing  democrats and saying how bad things are  under democrats  they're not supposed to straight up say  that that we're not a good country and  trump you always say america is the best  america is the best always but trump  actually now saying america is not great  right now because frankly whether you  like it or not and some people like  america is not great now we're laughing  stock all over the world and you know i  really think the borders are a horror  show but i really think that so that's a  notable change in rhetoric but overall  a really scary authoritarian fascist  delusion of a rally it's very clear that  these are going to continue there's one  scheduled for two weeks to the day after  this one on january 29th